wie schwierig war es für für ihre
familie sich damals in deutschland zu
integrieren und das zu schaffen was
jetzt geschafft haben und haben sie
vielleicht ein tipp für diejenigen die
in den vergangenen jahren aus syrien vor
allem was die letzten jahre angeht nach
deutschland gekommen sind haben sie da
einen ratschlag und vielleicht auch
abschließend eine nachricht an
diejenigen die diesen menschen probleme
bereiten und politisch insbesondere bei
der ard gegen diese menschen hetzen
also ich hab keinen politischen
ratschlag ich für mich ist es wichtig
dass wir dass wir in einer gesellschaft
leben wo wir uns gegenseitig
respektieren und wo wir die möglichkeit
schaffen dass jeder jeder seinen träumen
seiner träume und seine ziele erreichen
kann
für die familien die die aus den
verschiedenen ländern gekommen sind
für meine eltern war es sehr wichtig
dass ich dass ich zur schule gehen dass
ich studieren wollen
und sie haben jeden tag gearbeitet jeden
morgen um 34 auf gebracht und sind dann
zur arbeit gegangen weil sie eben den
traum hatte dass das dass ihre kinder
mal etwas besseres werden können
studieren kann und ich glaube das ist
ein ganz wichtiger wichtige idee das
wäre das werden dass wir besondere
rücksicht auf kinder nehmen und
besonders bei kindern fragen wie können
wir kinder zu fördern
wir können das kindern ermöglichen ihre
fähigkeiten fähigkeiten zu nutzen und
sich weiterzuentwickeln und dann
wiederum wiederum für die gesellschaft
tätig zu werden und und und da gibt es
ganz viele verschiedene weg aber das
wichtigste aus meiner sicht sind die
kinder dass das kindern ermöglichen
möglichst an an hervorragenden
schulischen werdegang mit möglichkeiten
in verschiedene verschiedener berufs
informations richtung zu gehen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren